good morning John this morning I was
watching an old Vlog Brothers video with
Orin and he said data that's you before
your injury now when I tell you I did
not know what to say it's because I did
not know what to say but when I think
about how it affected him this makes
sense because it was like Daddy couldn't
do a lot of stuff you had to be careful
with me I like parts of me hurt really
bad I couldn't pick him up or wrestle I
was injured I had an injury we talked
about it as cancer but we didn't really
explain what cancer was to him in part
because like I I know what cancer is and
it's really complicated and I'm just not
the kind of guy who like makes stuff
simple so it's not surprising that he
would be confused especially because
everyone is confused epitomized by the
fact that we still are calling cancers
cancer I'm on a mission to get this to
stop there is no such thing as cancer
just like there's no such thing as virus
there are Cancers and there are viruses
you don't get injury you get an injury
different injuries are different from
each other cancer is anywhere between
like hundreds to billions of diseases
hundreds because there are some common
pathways through which normal healthy
cells can become cancerous cells
classical hodkin lymphoma is a pathway
through which normal healthy cells can
become cancerous cells and because of
that classical hodkin lymphoma cells
behave similar to each other so people
with classical hodkin lymphoma have
similar prognoses and respond roughly
the same to similar treatments billions
because
every single cancer is genetically
distinct just like every person is
genetically distinct and so two people
with the exact same kind of classical
hodkin lymphoma can respond differently
to treatment because their bodies are
different the micro environments between
their cells are different their genomes
are different their epigenetics are
different their immune systems are
different indeed by the time a cancer is
Advanced you don't really even have one
cancer anymore there's a lot of genetic
variation in the population of cancer
inside of a body which is why late St
age cancer is so difficult to treat
because there's a lot of genetic
variation which allows the cancer to
handle whatever we throw at it now of
course I understand that this is going
to seem pedantic to a lot of people but
I think that calling Cancer's cancer
does harm in at least two specific clear
ways that I experien first people who
have watched someone live through and
then die of a cancer will then think
when they see someone else who has
cancer or when they themselves get
cancer they will think that that that's
going to be the same situation
and that can create a lot of
hopelessness and a lot of sometimes even
resistance to treatment I had a friend
who upon hearing kind of started to
treat me as if I was already dead
because that's how he was thinking that
cancer is cancer and I've seen how this
goes and second it leads to this belief
that I hear over and over again that we
have failed that despite all the
mountains of money and time and effort
we have thrown at trying to cure cancer
we have failed at curing cancer and this
is just
wrong not because we haven't cured
cancer because cancer doesn't exist it's
not a disease it's a kind of disease we
also haven't cured bacteria like people
still die of bacterial infections some
bacterial infections are uncurable oh
most of them are curable but some aren't
there's some cancers that we can cure
some cancers that we cannot and there's
a whole Spectrum in the middle of
cancers that respond variously well to
different treatments in fact we recently
passed a milestone in the US more than
half of people diagnosed with cancer
will not be killed by that disease they
will either be cured or they will die
with it rather than of it this is going
to sound kind of nihilistic because this
is how we're used to talking but a cure
for cancer cannot exist because there
are at minimum hundreds of cancers and
they're all different from each other
gly blastoma is as different from hodkin
lymphoma as Ebola is from the common Cal
we don't get to cure cancer we have to
cure Cancers and that's just more work
but it's the truth of the matter weirdly
enough calling my cancer an injury for
me is actually more accurate than
calling it cancer because at least we
understand in our brain that not all
injuries are the same John I'll see you
on Tuesday